overseas Italy is taking unprecedented
steps to slow an alarming jump in the
number of coronavirus cases its northern
region home to around 16 million people
has been under a virtual lockdown since
yesterday Italy is the hardest hit
country in Europe with more than 7,300
reported infections Charlie d'Agata is
in Rome Charlie why is the country
enacting such drastic measures
well Michelle there are now new measures
that include shutting down the Coliseum
for the first time since this crisis
began why because every evening at
around 6 o'clock we get the new figures
in every evening we've seen those
numbers jump when I first reported this
one week ago today they're around 1700
cases that has now quadrupled with the
death toll leaping by more than 50% in
one day from 233 to 366 the race to save
each life has become a military
operation inside that bio containment
unit is a 62 year old woman surrounded
by emergency teams taking every
precaution they can Italians are just
coming to terms with a shocking new
reality the quarantine of a quarter of
the country's population nobody in or
out a forced lockdown that includes a
financial capital of Milan and Venice
one of Italy's main tourist draws
Italy's beloved soccer games played
behind closed doors fans are banned at
the Vatican Pope Francis live-streamed
his Sunday blessing on wide screens
instead of his papal apartment window to
discourage crowds from gathering though
he did make a surprise appearance when
it was over in Rome suburb the faithful
celebrated Mass outdoors notice the
distance between them adhering to
government advice that members of the
public should stay three feet away from
one another
keep a safe distance so we can pray
together
so one parishioner but given the
problems nowadays it is important that
we pray together Italy has enacted the
most drastic measures outside of China
because Italy's outbreak is one of the
worst in the world out
of China where there is hope of a
turnaround that country has reported no
new cases outside its hardest-hit
province for two days running now it's
not just the lockdown in the north
nationwide museums have been closed
weddings and funerals have been
suspended and the elderly especially had
been told please just stay at home
Tony incredible pictures there Charlie
d'Agata for us in Rome Charlie thank you
very much